we did it Jimmy congratulations we did
it yes we did what you do by the way ah
support I i routed I yelled I thank you
Fred but did you have the best car
yesterday I did for the final two I and
I didn't um man what a wild change of
events the way that thing unfolded you
know watched the other championship the
other three championship for drivers
just kind of I'll run you all day long
and I could work my way to fit their six
but that was about it so at the end when
it mattered though we we we had the car
to get the job done what were you told
in your headset with the Carl Edwards
crash really nothing was told I could
see it all happen in front of me I
assumed both cars were out I was
surprised when she was able to continue
on as I passed them both I thought
they're both going to wall pretty hard
so thankful that I didn't get caught up
in it and assumed at that point I was
just really raced in the 18 but then the
points you made it back out how much
sleep have you had about an hour not
much if you had to race today good
wouldn't be a good idea would not hear
good idea how did you celebrate um so I
didn't leave the track until probably
first two o'clock attention of all the
media obligations and then had some
friends in South Beach and caught up
with them my team and went back to the
hotel room and I had a had a beer with
my wife and a couple other friends and
then went to bed actually started
packing then then went to bed and only
have an hours sleep for it get up get
get to the car what's the offseason
gonna be like I should be pretty relaxed
to look forward to catching up it's been
such a grind looking through the final
months of the season and I really see
some family time capped with my apology
kids seven titles put you in that
rarified air has it sunk in what's it
mean to it's starting to think yeah I
mean I've never been one that's pay
attention to stats
I really understand the situation i'm in
and what we've been able to accomplish
but it's just it's wow that's like I'm
watching a movie for someone else the
White House with did you do watch
football on Sunday before the race do
you keep up or do you even have the
opportunity to you care no I do care i
haven't had a chance to watch much this
year but we're always racing um you know
honestly when the games are taking place
but you guys don't have a fantasy team
dude i joined one once in the giraffe
took so long I'm gonna die wait a minute
it's me away what takes longer the draft
or a race that's true that's a good
argument I give you that um I guess this
is kind of awkward but you were in
studio last week and yeah I thought you
know we kind of built up a pretty good
bond thereof may be adding something to
the man cave here and you know Denny
Hamlin has his steering wheel from when
he won Daytona 500 so I threw this out
to Carl and Joey last Tuesday here and
then I'll get your reaction okay if one
of you two wins then how about the
gloves oh cool all right is that all
right that's absolutely ax you got it
what will mount them will Hamlin's
steering wheel from Daytona might get a
little bit more okay that we have people
get the idea so so you were in the back
room watching that Jimmy and I kind of
was asking you through them if you won I
thought the deal was my dirty socks
Paulie did we answered you brought up
dirty socks as well hmm I'll take it SSS
ax oh this is something for the man cave
and it's got to go above them of
whatever didn't have 1,000,000 there wow
wow okay I software you gave your helmet
to Tony Stewart yes I did oh that's
pretty list he was asking um if you the
drivers to treat you know to trade
helmets in the fall season and I I don't
know I thought about it before the race
if I may be really cool if I was able to
win this race still not helmets I know
how much would mean to him I mean a lot
to me for for him to have it in his
collection and you walked up on stage to
congratulate us in I was like
you know this is the time ice cream down
to some guys by the car they pulled a
helmet out in handed to me and I was a
low gear to him midi cry no no it didn't
didn't go there he was blown away and
he's like man I can't take it I said no
you've got to take it they gave me the
disclaimer that if I ever wanted it back
all I had to do is fall you're not
getting it back yeah I don't know you're
not hey I know you have a busy day
congrats it was great seeing you in the
man cave last week and hopefully you get
some rest in the offseason Thank You
Jimmy i preciate that thing death all
right there you go the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience